[Musik]
eine junge frau demonstriert zusammen
mit anderen tier aktivisten vor einem
schweinestall die tränen schießen ihren
die augen was hat sie erlebt waren ist
sie so berührt
davon handelt diese geschichte
da
[Musik]
anja es steht ständig unter strom
sie hat einen anstrengenden job in der
freizeit ist sieht ihr aktivist manchmal
streift sie durch den wald sucht nach
entspannung vor allem dann wenn sie sich
über andere menschen geärgert hat auf
dem weg zwischen wald und wohnung kommt
die junge tierschützerin an einem
bauernhof vorbei dort sind kälber in
plastikboxen eingesperrt sind
unglücksort aber wir ganz nah gewesen
beklagte wird dieser boxen verbringt
also mit auf wie zu gewinnen muss blutig
sein damit man nicht schlecht aber ein
netter hund sorgt das wird die augen
schaue und einmal so anja es könnten
bauern schon lange
sie findet ihn nett und plaudert
manchmal mit ihm die aktivistin stört
sich daran dass er selber von der mutter
getrennt
sie weiß der bauer hat keine andere wahl
aber diskutieren wie sie trotzdem mit
ihm seine frau sagt er sei leider nicht
den kopf er das messer weg selten also
zusammen acs bereitet sich seit monaten
darauf vor
zusammen mit anderen tierschützern einer
aktion auf einem bauernhof durchzuführen
das ganze land soll davon erfahren
letztere familie mutig schoko tiere
wollen rechte genau wie wir tiere wollen
freiheit genau wie wir druck zuständig
ist und es mehr gewonnen als ihr
besitzer sie hat mir die präsentation
ganz kabinettsmitglied gerade und
ecommerce der plan soll an stall besetzt
werden welche das ist noch geheim
der betroffene bauer darf keinen
verdacht schöpfen und mit vor informiert
über den haben natürlich mit ganz
verstellbar und von anderen ort und das
sage aber wirklich auch quasi erstellt
vom alltags über nach aufzeigen was war
passiert
auf der dritten stufe ich freue mich
weil website ist noch nie passiert ist
und in den ferien auch für die reine ist
bislang sehr hat einmal bin ich sehr
gespannt
ein samstag im august jener tag auf den
die aktivisten monatelang hingearbeitet
haben ist endlich da über 60
tierschützerinnen und tierschützer aus
sieben ländern sind nach zürich gereist
jeder hat seine aufgabe auch habe die
fall ist dann noch mal geklickt bitte
dass sie den welchem auto das ihr drin
zeigt die bürsten drin zum die schuhe
abstufung sind knapp auto geordnet
gucken dass wir die vom richtigen auto
nimmt und dann wieder einbrechen auto
zurücklegt
die annahme ist dass er stimmung wien
ein klassenlager junger leute die auf
ein abenteuer warten
ausgang ungewiss die aktivisten
schreiben die telefonnummer eines
anwalts auf ihren arm
falls sie bei der illegalen aktion
verhaftet werden ein eigens eingesetzter
pressesprecher erklärt den klar
wir können den schweinestall und was mir
weiter pixi wenn sie verloren aber das
label firmen trotzdem immer mit damit
verletze das tor hat bedeutet natürlich
und der wohl man dann sagt er das ist
eigentlich verhältnis zu gott der stau
trotzdem haben die probleme sich über
systembedingt
alles ist straff durchorganisiert jeder
weiß in welchem auto er sitzt und welche
aufgabe er bei der hof besetzung
übernehmen wird
während der fahrt beginnen die
aktivisten handschuhe überzustreifen
es geht darum dass niemand die tiere im
stall ansteckt
anja es macht alles wohl überlegt auch
das einkaufen
sie sucht gemüse aus dass gerade wächst
und möglichst aus der region stammt das
darf auch etwas mehr kosten
obwohl anja s er knapp bei kasse ist
seit zweieinhalb jahren lebt die tier
aktivistin vegan
ihr damaliger freund hat ihr die augen
geöffnet ist das jetzt wo sie heute
[Musik]
schlachtfleisch gast sehr krasse die
ganze zeit eigentlich auf die produkte
einsetzen
das scheint sie vegan lebt hat anja es
eine gewisse in toleranz gegenüber
andersdenkenden entwickelt sie teilt die
welt ein in fleischesser und veganer
würde sie haben das mit der prämie
fleisch
mit mahnwachen abfangen am schlachthof
können jetzt können wenn sie beinhalten
sind wir nach so schön stück fleisch
genau das nicht mit ihnen erzählt das
heißt dass es einen kern hatte aber
immer wieder momente die sie an taten
komme nach untersuchung mit ein bisschen
krasser pflanzen
wenn anja es zu hause liest dinther
seltene entspannung
sie bildet sich gerade weiterliest ein
praxishandbuch für linker aktivisten
das soll helfen wenn es bei der
geplanten aktion brenzlig wird
das heißt die repression in ihrem fall
ist ja einfach zum teil übernehmen
baupolizei nach tanks die jacke mit
sache ziemlich programm nicht stimmen
einfach ein gewisses ja nicht und dann
hört man bei einer ruft zum beispiel
wurde mit sehr hoher unverhältnismäßiger
strophen
genau das ist aber reine theorie dass
ein sich aber nie erlebt haben
das leder aber aus dem spiel sauer und
habe eine chance auch nicht stehen was
man das dokument nicht sagen dass sie
gar nicht erst eine dänische hauptstadt
der autokonvoi der aktivisten nähert
sich dem bauern die teilnehmer ziehen
ihre schutzanzüge an hygiene ist
oberstes gebot
annina den amis bringen
zu sicher ob es jetzt
noch mehr man heute mit aura übte von
aktivisten schlagen alarm sie sagen die
schutzanzüge die verteilt worden sind
seien luftdurchlässig hat er 21
du bist dir da sie diese kinder
nein
beide sind froh mit ihm einen ball kommt
gefährlich für alle die da drin sind
es müssten jetzt
ich komme nicht mit rein aber ihr wisst
dass ihr alle anderen gefährdet die
mitmachen und jeder muss das selber
entscheiden dass diese nicht weiße wände
durchatmen kann sind die nicht beim ski
der präsentation
ja dann haben wir keine ahnung davon was
weiß ich
wir entscheiden aber es ist super
gefährlichen freund von jennifer an
diesem tag hatten schon gestorben die
man darin kriegen kann
das ist super gefährlich für alle die
mitmachen
daran können menschliche haben daran
kann die tiere sterben also ist das dann
wirklich wert es gibt nicht nur mich
geben auf einem parkplatz beraten sich
die aktivisten wie soll es weitergehen
nachdem sich herausgestellt hat dass die
schutzanzüge auch nicht wasserdicht sind
einhellige meinung weitermachen es soll
eine aktion vor dem stall geben
ende der diskussion die zeit drängt
[Musik]
gut
können wir kapieren züge noch nicht raus
die gruppenliga
erst jetzt verschickt anja es per sms
die information wo genau sich der hof
befindet
ja es ist reines herz die aktion bleibt
bis zum schluss streng geheim
jetzt nähert sich die gruppe dem
bauernhof es gilt ernst die
star-besetzung beginnt
so heißt es für anja es nicht das erste
mal
sie hat sich am hof besetzungen in
holland slowenien großbritannien und
frankreich beteiligt dort werden tiere
oft in riesigen ställen gehalten dass
die anfangs ist gesund menschen die
quasi dementi die kameras da sie aber
scheint logisch ist hat sie gewählt wenn
sie sich da nie drin aber ich habe
stattdessen flüchtet wäre dass man dann
einfach sehen als bergführer wollen also
bereit war luzia schlösser und burgen
die genetik brauchen damit aus stangen
und für mehr normale der aktion mein
glück nicht wäre polizei erhöhte mit
einem autogramm und es hat doch gar
nicht der fox in einem gewaltigen
medienauflauf gab es bei einer stall
besetzung in holland unterwegs und sehr
emotional über 100 betrieben und
nachbereitung sie hat eine wunderbare
vorlage und wohin sie auch das vermisste
warum bisher 10
zimperlich gehen die bauern mit den
besetzern nicht um
nicht in holland nicht in frankreich und
wie wird es in der schweiz seien alle
sind gespannt
der film fangen
aus
mit einem spezial einkleben die
aktivisten ihre hände zusammen
falls die polizei sie abtransportieren
will wird er es schwer haben
als erstes wird dann transparent
aufgespannt
die nachbarschaft soll wissen dieser hof
ist besetzt
doch was heißt überhaupt stopp
speziesismus spezies muss erst wenn ein
spezielles größer mächtiger fängt als
eine andere spezies spricht die atmend
hält sich wertvoller als ein schwein als
ein hund eine katze egal was diese
überheblichkeit entscheidet dass eine
andere spezies gequält missbraucht und
getötet werden kann und das ganz
selbstverständlich und legal
wieso sind sie ypsilanti die
aufmerksamkeit für die option eins ist
für das schöne blumen aber wichtig
unseren verbracht ich sehe ich jetzt
nicht so also nehme die tiere denen von
pfarrer bringen für äußerste also für
die stahl besetzung wird live auf
facebook übertragen
80.000 schauen zu
noch einmal für die aktion geschadet
haben wir sind in der schweiz lanciert
die erste farbe setzung in der schweiz
der mann dazu entschieden
draußen zu bleiben da wir entschieden
dass die anzüge für diejenigen drin und
für uns selber nicht sicher genug werden
und wir nicht riskieren wollen
das darf man jemand schaden trägt
deswegen haben wir gesagt dass die
aktion den orten stattfinden kann
sehen wir uns draußen an nun so dass wir
unsere forderung trotzdem genauso
stellen kann und unsere forderungen sind
das wissen wir dass bereits hier ist
rein darf in den stall um zu filmen wie
drinnen auto sie werden aber gleich auf
den fernseher kriens mit gewalt
aufzeigen was vorher drin vermittelt
wurde
anja es soll sich um die technik kümmert
dafür muss sie erst ihre verklebten
hände lösen
gut dass du so viel kleber rausgegangen
und gehe ich kommen bereichen mit mit
dem fernseher und dann komme ich wieder
einige aktivisten tragen bildschirm
darauf sollen videos für die
medienvertreter abgespielt werden
doch von der presse ist keiner da die
aufnahmen aus dem stall sind kürzlich
gemacht worden
sie zeigen medikamente auf verrotteten
regalen und schweine die an einem nabel
bruch leiden
santos aufnahmen vom inneren vom
stadtjugendamt ja das darf natürlich das
signal für den tierschutz 48 48 ganz
genau
und jetzt schon sagen
die aktion hat jetzt ein anderes thema
hat sie heute starb setzte sich vor dem
schweizer mittel haben eigene
funktionieren
wir haben uns zwar feststellen hier sind
der bio secure das heißt wir deutlich
natur und müll sagte problematik station
lose pandemie einstellen ja über die ja
über die er oder über fleischkonsum und
darum sind wir da sehr vorsichtigen
interessen cheater einfache muster
bereits bleiben und wie möglich vom pool
her bewegt dass wir mit der medien mit
personen sind das heißt aktion jetzt
bezüglich schutzanzüge schnitt ganz
perfekt vorbereitet wollte sich schon
perfekt vorbereitet sie sich einfach bei
mangel hat man entdeckt dass da etwas
kälter die aufnahmen im innern des
stalls zeigen kranke werken
sie liegen zuckend am boden und sterben
langsam
wenn sie tot sind kommen sie in eine
tiefkühltruhe frau genau dieser
tiefkühltruhe stehen jetzt die
aktivisten sie schauen nach ob die tiere
immer noch darin liegen dass alles
dokumentieren sie mit der kamera die
bilder wollen sie der öffentlichkeit
zugänglich machen
mitten in die aufkommende lethargie
trifft bauer auf dem hof ein
[Musik]
kostet ab ohne jemand anzuschauen geht
er an den aktivisten vorbei in den stall
was tun
wieder singen und sich selbst mut machen
und hoffen dass der bauer aus dem stall
kommt und sich den aktivisten stellt
anja es auf dem weg zur arbeit die 25
jährige macht eine ausbildung zur
pflegerin bei der spitex definitiv mit
produkte körpers
man muss liegt hinter uns das ist
definitiv sehr aussteigen
macht ja nicht weg spannend es ist eine
halbe stelle die anja es bei der spitex
hat ihr leben ist eine achterbahn voll
gespickt mit beruflichen und privaten
terminen wenn sie sich nicht ums tier
wohl kümmert hilft sie kranken eine
kombination die zu ihr passt
und auch nicht so gut ausdrücken wie
awesome sie und probiert sie wenn der
alte hase ist halt irgendwie etwas
richtig positives das wichtigste aus
dass möglich verkaufen und gegen deshalb
die schönsten seite sicher meinen job
glücklich machen und er bis zur alpha
syn throm nicht unbedingt also und wenn
es so ist eigentlich sehr positiv
die polizei rückte an
der bauer hat sie gerufen für die
aktivisten an heikler moment
sie können nicht abschätzen ob die lage
eskaliert räumt die polizei den
bauernhof kommen die besetzer ins
gefängnis eine aktivistin hat die
aufgabe mit den polizisten zu reden
die hören geduldig zu und machen sich
auf die suche nach dem bauern der sich
immer noch im stall eingesperrt hatte
[Musik]
trotz der unruhe auf dem hof werden die
tiere immer zutraulicher allmählich
gewöhnen sie sich an die vielen fremden
leute sie lassen sich sogar streichen
was empfinden sie wenn sie dort die
schweine streichen
das sind genauso fühlende lebewesen wie
wir und ich werden die einen ihren
eigenen ausscheidungen und handeln die
tiere so als ob sie weniger wert sind
nur weil sie anders aussehen weil sie
eine andere nase haben weil die anderen
haben wir sind unsere sprache sprechen
eine groteske situation tierschützer mit
friedensgruß stehen unbefugt auf einem
fremden bauernhof singen befreiungs
lieder
der bauer hat sich eingeschlossen die
polizei versucht die lage zu erfassen
auf einmal kommt der bauer aus dem staub
er will mit dem traktor nach hause
fahren die aktivisten verhindern dass
[Applaus]
hartnäckig suchen sie einen dialog mit
dem bauern
sie blockieren seine weiterfahren doch
der bauer lässt sich nicht provozieren
[Applaus]
er schaut sie nicht an sagt kein wort
als ihm klar wird dass er nicht
wegfahren kann lässt er sich von der
polizei heimbringen sprach öffnen wir
die vorträge stellen weitere schritt mit
der polizei ich fahre hat sie behandelt
wie luft wären sie dass endlich eine
spürt xi und natürlich verzweifelt und
damit auch immer man bauen
zum einen haben wir klar kommen wie
weiter die stimmung unter den aktivisten
verschlechtert sich
alle sind müde und lustlos auf einmal
spricht sich unter den aktivisten herum
dass die polizei etwas vorhat das keine
aktivist mehr reingehen
[Musik]
anja es weit die aktivisten in den neuen
plan
sonst haben wir können nichts verlauten
wir haben die produktion oder die
polizei interessiert nicht groß dass wir
hier sind muss man machen könnten um zu
behaupten dass einfach je nachdem
mehrere zwei oder noch mehr ins büro
gehen bevor es jetzt noch alles
abwiegeln und uns dafür sorgen werde
dass für alle ob es geht los
die tür zum stall ist immer noch
abgeschlossen die aktivisten suchen an
anderen weg um ins büro zu gelangen
[Musik]
jetzigen
die polizisten überlegen wie sie
reagieren sollen
wenn ich für den gebrauch gemacht
mit im rennen vielleicht und begründete
[Musik]
das heißt nichts weiter zu
da man da machen und bewusst
anja es ist nicht nur eine unermüdliche
kämpferin
sie hat auch eine zarte verletzliche
musische seite mit ihrem cello 14 die
nächste stadt
dort spielt sie im kammerorchester es
ist die erste probe seitdem corona
lockdown
aber natürlich 1000 aber noch an in der
hoffnung so zieht
so wie früher pilot ob khs hvv immer
noch sehr geehrt
[Musik]
teamplay richtig ist wenn sie mit geld
zusammenkaufen meldete mythischen mail
[Musik]
es ist still im schweinestall kein
mensch weit und breit
geplant war dass aktivisten sich hier
hinsetzen und erst weg gehen wenn der
bauer mit ihnen verhandelt daraus ist
nichts geworden
alles hier drin bleibt gespenstisch
ruhig im büro des bauern befinden sich
immer noch einige aktivist sie haben
sich umgesehen und dabei einiges
entdeckt
die kannibalismus spray der wettiner
gesprüht damit dieses tages die devise
wo sie kurz nach sie im tutti ist oder
man sie dann natürlich umgebung sollte
sie genau und das fehlt einfach denn zu
verhaltensstörungen
es ist stickig hier drin die leute sind
hungrig und müde
sie wollen raus
das ende der stall besetzung wird für
eine live-übertragung im internet
inszeniert ein teil der aktivisten geht
ins freie
der rest der gruppe empfängt sie draußen
mit gesang
[Musik]
dies soll die abschlussfeier des tages
seien aber zum feiern ist kaum einem
zumute
[Musik]
nein
es ist eben mercedes mann ist weiß was
passiert und das hat ihn hier erwartet
sind dran sorgen so ist jetzt emotional
so dass wenn so eine tafel birstein auch
noch mit dem hintergrund warteten
tausende mit darstellen es war ein tag
der fleischesser zum umdenken anregen
sollte aber die tierschützer blieben
unter sich
die öffentlichkeit hat kaum notiz davon
genommen
die aktivisten geben deswegen nicht auf
sie wollen bald einen neuen stall
besetzen
anja es wird bestimmt dabei sein
[Musik]